[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir ouaga 2000
bonsoir chez vous alors ce soir je vais
vous parler des quartiers de ouagadougou
des vrais quartier ceux qui sont
aménagés et construit par leurs
résidants ceux où vivent 4 ouagalais sur
dix et qui occupe un quart du territoire
de l'agglomération
ces quartiers comment sont ils chacun
chacune a sa petite idée
je vous invite à les découvrir pourquoi
se développe-t-il et quel est leur
avenir
je voudrais partager avec vous quelques
idées et réflexions
en guise de réponse à ces trois
questions
mais avant soyons bien clair je ne vous
parle pas des quartiers l'outil ou la
moitié de parcelles sont vides ni des
coins chauds de ouaga où la nuit en bois
jusqu'à ne plus être lucide jeu
le pas non plus de ces quartiers huppés
où les résidents ont été précédés par le
coûteront l'eau et l'électricité je vous
parle des quartiers de ouagadougou des
frères un quartier ceux où les gens
vivent circulent se parlent rient et
pleurent ensemble ceux où les gens
discutent se disputent puisse de
réconcilier par ceux où les riverains ne
se disent bonjour que deux fois par an
aux fêtes du nouvel an et à celle du
ramadan par ceux où les voisins ne se
croisent jamais emprisonné avec leurs
chiens et leur gardien derrière leurs
hautes clôtures enrobé de fils barbelés
non moi je vous parle des quartiers sur
de ouagadougou des vrais quartier sur
ceux où en période de grandes chaleurs
mars avril on peut dormir tranquille
ventre en l'air à la belle étoile et la
porte entrouverte bien sûr ceux où le
voleur n'a rien à voler mais que
l'opinion qualifie pourtant de lieu
d'insécurité de refuge aux brigands et
de toutes formes de criminalité ce que
l'on cache aux touristes et aux
étrangers
ce qui sur les plans officiels ne sont
jamais représentés
ces quartiers qu'on oublie mais dont on
ne se souvient qu'à la veille des
élections
ces quartiers qui font peur peur juste
parce qu'ils sont différents
on les accuse de rage et de toutes
formes de pathologies pour mieux
légitimer et justifier leur destruction
leur démolition leur déguerpissement que
dis-je le mot diplomatiquement correct
est leur lotissement
pourtant je vous parle des quartiers
aménagés de ouagadougou des vrais
quartier aménagé ce dont les rues sont
adaptés aux plus nombreux des usagers
motocyclistes cyclistes marcheurs
marcheuse à pied et au l'ambulance je
précise peut malgré tout passé oui je
vous parle de ces jolies petites ruelles
qui mesure et qu'on appelle
affectueusement si m pas de ces gros sa
venue dans l'emprise de 40 mètres mais
où on a seulement aménager une languette
de 7 mètres au milieu de déchets d'eau
musée de hautes herbes et de chèvres
qu'on les spectres je vous parle des
quartiers aménagés dont les rues sont en
forme de spaghettis bien cuit où les
enfants s'amusent en courant dans la rue
y compris les plus petits pas
le ou les rues sont toutes pareilles
monotone et bien droites pas ceux où les
riverains sont numérotées et rangés
comme dans des boîtes cher citadins et
citadine votre attention s'il vous plaît
car je vous parle de la ville de
ouagadougou des vrais coeur de ville ce
qui bat au rythme du temps de la
débrouille et des opportunités du moment
feu où les résidents remplissent des
sacs de terre pour construire des ponts
ou pour protéger leur construction de
l'érosion
je vous parle des quartiers son
électricité officiel mais où des
panneaux solaires et des batteries
usagées puis recharger éclaire la nuit
il clair la vie loin très loin des
grognes et des plaintes du fait de la
énième coupure
loin très très loin des gaspillage d'eau
potable qui arrose des pelouse à grands
jets d'eau après avoir arrosé des
voitures à granges et de seaux d'eau
loin de nous ces quartiers entre non il
existe et inch'allah ils existeront on
les appelle au burkina à ouaga busy bien
tenter sa chance
nogué what's in home à bath béret dicko
fait boire à yanqing à tabatinga en côte
d'ivoire boribana au brésil au kenya
plus tôt libéra l'un des plus grands
bidonvilles au monde au brésil
ruth sheen a malheureusement on appelle
ces favelas segreto c'est glauque blanc
parce qu'ils ne sont pas non lotis non
formelle non réguliers non aménagés et
sur d et si l'on décidé d'appeler un
deal quartier l'outil non spontanée non
populaire non vie sans vie non j'ai pas
envie ces quartiers existe parce qu'ils
sont une histoire c'est l'histoire d'un
ancien village traditionnel avec son
organisation socio culturel rattrapé par
l'urbanisation
c'est aussi l'histoire de nouveaux
quartiers urbains attirés par les
lotissements qui rôdent à la faveur de
l'implantation de nouvel équipement
structurant
oui
très simplement que se passe-t-il
concrètement des terrains exploités sont
délimités par les premiers occupants
offerts à des tiers qui demande
l'hospitalité
puis ces terrains sont à nouveau
morcelée par ces derniers et vendu bien
plus cher à de nouveaux arrivés ne nous
voilons pas la face on fait affaire avec
la terre loin de l'esprit de nos pères
et de nos traditions séculaires
aujourd'hui la population mondiale de
ces quartiers est estimée tenez vous
bien à plus d'un milliard d'hommes et de
femmes de garçons et de filles qui n'ont
pas d'autre choix que de vivre là en
définitive ces quartiers sont une
alternative pour des centaines de
millions de citadins en quête de
logement est en croissance massive
ils sont mis à la touche par le marché
immobilier formelle qui avouons le à une
offre très limitée et surtout inadaptés
à leurs conditions réelles à titre
d'exemple à ouagadougou
la demande est de 20 milles logements
par an alors qu'en dix ans entre 2007 et
l'état l'a fait construire que 5000
logements
en effet il ne suffit pas de leur offrir
quatre bornes à la périphérie
en espérant qu'ils iront y construire
leur logis loin de leur école de leur
marché de leur maternité de leurs
dispensaires loin de leur travail et de
leurs opportunités d'affaires
quartier existe justement parce qu'ils
offrent l'opportunité à des jeunes de
décohabiter de leur famille première
partie leur offre l'opportunité de
fonder leur propre famille nucléaire
parce qu'ils sont des lieux d'emploi et
de création de richesse des lieux de
créativité d'innovation et de prouesses
presse pour avoir un toit pour avoir un
passage une voix prouesse pour avoir de
l'eau pour avoir des caniveaux prouesse
pour avoir de la lumière pour avoir de
la vie pour vivre heureux
digne et fière
chaque matin se lever et dire oui à 15,1
inquiet ça va aller lafi bala hwan park
je vois certains d'entre vous sourire du
coin des lèvres et se dire tout ça c'est
bien beau c'est du discours c'est même
poétique avec des rimes et des verts
mais dans la réalité sur le terrain
ces quartiers sont bel et bien précaire
certainement
je vous le concède parce que personne
n'a de titre légal de propriété et que
d'autres se sont installés sur des
terrains impropres à l'habitat et
risquent d'être délocalisés en cas de
régularisation foncière
mais je serais beaucoup plus nuancée
quant à leur précarité économique
on trouve de plus en plus de
fonctionnaires de l'administration
publique d'hommes et de femmes
ordinaires dans ces quartiers et les
personnes aisées qui possède même des
villas jumelées dans des quartiers
l'outil chic on peut aussi relativisé la
précarité des infrastructures dans la
mesure où les quartiers loti riverains
ont les mêmes niveaux d'équipement
minimaliste et des services urbains de
conjoncture alors on peut le dire
ces quartiers ont un avenir un avenir
autre que celui d'une destruction
brutale en y substituant une nouvelle
trame urbaine fonctionnel et orthogonale
ses quartiers en un avenir autre que ces
préjugés qui stigmatisent leur précarité
et leur vulnérabilité
ces quartiers ont un avenir autre que ce
discours accusateur qui consiste à dire
ce sont tous des spéculateurs qui
attendent d'avoir une parcelle pour la
revendre et à les construire un nouveau
nom l'outil ailleurs en réalité
qui sont les grands spéculateurs de nos
cités en parle ici de quelques dizaines
de mètres carrés alors qu'on sait que
des centaines d'hectares sont accaparés
par des promoteurs immobiliers privés et
des individus fortunés aux périphéries
de nos lieux habités huit quartiers en à
venir un vrai avenir celui du nouveau
regard porté par les résidents sur eux
mêmes celui du nouveau regard porté par
les non résidents sur ces quartiers
c'est la restauration de l'estimé de soi
par les résidents c'est la
reconnaissance de leur existence et de
leur urbanité des savoirs et
savoir-faire des résidents par les
experts et les gouvernants c'est l'auto
construction
c'est l'avenir de l'auto construction
dans ces quartiers c'est la
professionnalisation des artisan maçon
soudeur tâcherons menusier qui fabrique
des lieux de vie de rencontres de
passage des espaces de confiance
réciproque et de partage qui cultive des
valeurs de solidarité et de tolérance
qui met en avant l'intérêt commun au
détriment de leur propre pitance
l'avenir de ces quartiers est fondée sur
le respect et la sauvegarde de
l'environnement
c'est construire la ville sur elle-même
en l'améliorant c'est le bonheur
d'habiter dans un quartier populaire
oui le bonheur de vivre dans un quartier
ouvert un quartier ouvert sur et moderne
de sens une modernité à construire
chaque jour avec des murs avec des murs
et avec des murs murs d'humanité intense
[Musique]